also
we've looked at the balance between just
characters and the um
debate team in after camera and now I'm
happy to say that we have considered in
the balance of the protected
characteristics against the rest of the
proposals that we accept this in one and
we obviously recommendation could I have
a second
that's what all those are accepting my
boss Reformation
recognition
and we watch the final item of this
evening which is
uh nine Diamond Row sales that's what
page and just today we'll give the
introduction
thank you chair
um this application relates to a
two-story assembly touched property on
the north side of Dublin Road in the
residential area of sale a lot of
questions thought they're actually a
first floor side extension to provide
additional floor space for the dwellings
earthquake
the applications of course it's a
committee because most of the council
has an interest in the application
the key issue is a consideration of the
proposals design the impact on those
instruments
and highways parking events
one objects has been received raising a
concern regarding the extension's
impacts on the level of natural light to
a landing window in the Navy line
um
you can see the uh the first floor
extension there that's the first floor
plan uh that's obviously relatively
modest extensional property towards the
front
um elevation drawings
photography with the neighboring
property um
as objective
and from the rear
and the side of making proxy
um officers consider the program would
not have enough accessible impact on the
immunity occupies they may have been
drawing given the window
the concerns related to does not still
remain hatch program and in any case the
impact on the light movement of the
existing situation would be limited
is therefore considerable development
will be acceptable in terms of in Python
residential community
the first is also considered to be
accessible in terms of design and visual
immunity and would not have any
unacceptable parking pass
application
yeah that's a wash nice chair look at
that picture he talked about in the
report I would have preferred if it was
a setback there is
Steven's just it's going to flush at the
front isn't it
yeah
yeah I suppose
in this case we consider that that was
uh was acceptable because of the modest
extension
foreign
[Music]
quickly
I'm sure okay
thank you